this is so funny it's one of the most
cringe-worthy FoxNews moments I've seen
in a long time and that's a very very
high bar to reach if you've ever watched
Fox News Fox News has this commentator
or analyst named Katie Pavlich Katie
Pavlich is 30 years old she's a quote
conservative and most importantly she's
extraordinarily ignorant she kind of as
a conservative star in a way she was
named blogger of the Year by CPAC she is
all sorts of these low information
propaganda books that right-wing
audiences love one called fast and
furious Barack Obama's bloodiest scandal
and it's shameless cover up another book
assault and flattery the truth about the
left and their war on women this is the
type of thing that she has written she's
a totally irresponsible
interviewer she interviewed Andrew
[ __ ] who's the father of one of the
victims of the Parkland school shooting
on Fox News some time ago the father
falsely claimed that Democrats were
registering criminals in Florida jails
to vote Pavelec didn't even challenge
the could the claim didn't say how do
you know that didn't say well do you
have any evidence that that's going on
completely irresponsible interviewer as
well so she appears on Fox News
yesterday and she makes the bizarre and
obviously false and also just really
dumb claim that America should be held
up as a beacon of anti slavery because
we were the first country to end slavery
within the first hundred and fifty years
of being a country which is both really
specific really irrelevant and also
wrong I mean it's just ridiculous in
every sense and this was so obviously
idiotic that a fellow Fox News host who
I believe goes by Kennedy and I don't
know if Kennedy is her first name or her
last name or both her first name and
last name I'm not really sure or just
kind of like a nickname I'm not sure
Kennedy has to say what the f are you
talking about let's take a look at the
video they they keep blaming America for
the sin of slavery but the truth is
throughout human history slavery has
existed and America came along as the
first country to end it within a hundred
and fifty years and we get no credit for
the
to move forward and try and be dead have
a very bloody civil war over the racial
injury minutes of the civil war right
particularly blacks in the south right
yeah that was not a yellow is bloody and
violent and deadly and there were Native
Americans everybody showed a point is
that we all of that a country that
decided to end it and we're still
dealing with the issue but if you want
to start a problem and to inflame racial
tension even more start blaming people
who have nothing to do with slavery for
the sin of slavery that is not fair
that's not the American Way and we
shouldn't be doing it yeah so we'll talk
about America being the first country to
ban slavery within a hundred and fifty
years of existence but first of all half
the country wanted slavery and went to
war to keep slavery and threatened to
leave the Union over wanting to keep
slavery and the people who stick to that
ideology today are all Republicans
they're all on the right okay so she's
calling the banning of slavery in the US
and achievement which it is it's the
right thing to do banning slavery is
good but it's one that was made by
people who opposed the right wing of
that time when we were going into the
Civil War phase of the United States and
as Kennedy correctly points out just
because slavery ended the path for black
people in the United States remained
difficult to use her framing an
understatement for a very long time it
created structural inequality that
persists today she says don't blame
people who have nothing to do with
slavery for slavery okay fine what about
recognizing that slavery was ended not
because the u.s. decided to end slavery
but because the Union was able to defeat
a huge portion of the country which was
the slave owning South which wanted to
keep slavery legal so that's part one
now let's discuss her other claim that
the United States should get credit for
being able to so quickly ban slavery it
only took a hundred and fifty years
after the creation of the country this
information exists in in history books
right the timeline between independence
and slavery for different countries is
far shorter than in the United States
you can debate well what do we count as
banning slavery when you ban the slave
trade are you banning the owning of
slaves we could sort of find different
data points but there are countries that
ban slavery before they were even really
countries Denmark is an example slave
trade banned in 1803 didn't become it's
sort of original constitutional monarchy
until 18-49 another example is my birth
country of Argentina Argentina banned
slavery in 1853 it was founded in 1810
that's just 43 years between
independence and ending slavery so it's
hard to sometimes even do an analysis of
this stuff Pat because it's so obviously
wrong but it's also so obviously
ignorant and it's also so obviously
irrelevant that it's stunning that it's
even allowed to sort of go only mildly
contested in the way that it often is
yeah wrong ignorant irrelevant I also
wonder why she wants to even make this
point on the left right now in the
Democratic primary we're having a
conversation about reparations for
slavery Julian Castro is making that a
pillar of his campaign and meanwhile on
Fox and Friends were talking about
whether or not the United States
deserves any credit for eventually
ending slavery after a bloody civil war
so I think that's just the state of the
country right now yeah and and you know
the the reparations conversation you
could be for or against reparations in
2019 and be a reasonable person and and
sort of have a sensible debate you
should be able to without question point
out that Katie Pavlich is wrong
by both the letter and the spirit of
what she's saying it's embarrassing and
most importantly it's a dumb point
because when the United States banned
slavery half the country didn't want to
and thought that it was worth going to
war over keeping slavery incredible
irrational ignorant happening on fox
news daily make sure to follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show while you're there follow me at
David Pakman quick break and we will
talk the Denise Hearn next it will be a
very interesting
conversation one of today's sponsors is
minds.com a social networking platform
that is committed to free speech
transparency privacy and fairly
compensating content creators it
basically combines many of the features
of sites like Facebook YouTube and
Twitter in one platform but mine's is
trying to solve a lot of the problems
that exist on major social networks on
mines you're not being spied on you're
not being tracked everything is
encrypted and private mine's as a
company can't even see any of your
personal data you're not going to see a
bunch of creepy ads showing you the same
products you were just looking at on
other websites and unlike other major
social networks the code that runs
minds.com
is publicly available it provides total
transparency and the ability for
developers to even contribute to the
project themselves for example on many
other social platforms you're only
reaching a tiny fraction of your
followers organically but on mine's the
newsfeed is 100% organic and you can see
for yourself how the algorithms actually
work every time you do something on
mine's like create content share like
someone else's content you earn minds
tokens which can be used to boost the
visibility of your own content you are
getting rewarded for participating in
and contributing to the network and
mines offers a feature kind of like
patreon where your fans can unlock your
premium content by sending you mines
tokens I encourage you to go check it
out at minds.com there's also a mobile
app and you can actually follow the
david pakman show on mines at minds.com
slash david pakman show I've also put a
link right underneath this video